Okay.
There's an outline up here.
I'm going to try to write a little
bigger from now on and it's been already
suggested. I use capital letters and maybe
practice my printing a little better.
I will do that too.
I'm not very high tech.
I will occasionally use some
visuals slides here and there,
a painting here and there,
an image now and then and certainly maps,
especially in dealing with the 1850s
in the coming of the civil war.
But every lecture we'll have an outline
in front of you and the intention in
every case is to get to the
fifth part of that outline.
I almost always do
almost,
uh,
but at least you'll have a,
a sense of the structure of the topics
or the themes that this lecture is
supposed to work. It's way through.
I do welcome your questions.
I'll ask at times if
you have any questions.
This is obviously a
terribly formal situation.
Me Up here on this stage and you out there
looking into your laptops in some cases,
uh,
doing whatever you're
doing on your laptops.
Just don't do what one
student did a year ago though.
He was right back there and that,
uh, that I always, like halfway back,
he came in,
it was the day I was lecturing on the
dred Scott decision for some reason I've
never forgotten that.
And you whipped out the Yale Daily News
and he just was enjoying the Yale Daily
News. I know it was that much to
read in it for that long at the time,
but he's just reading the Yale
Daily News in front of them.
And at one point I stopped
rather loudly and I said,
the dred Scott decision is not covered
in today's Yale Daily News and you didn't
hear me. So I shouted it
again. And by that time,
the whole class has meaning
to laugh or uncomfortably.
And he finally realized
it was going on tour,
got crumbled up his newspaper and walked
out the back and he never came back.
I felt a little badly about it,
but
just don't make it so obvious.
All right. Um, does everybody have a
syllabus? Anyone lacking a syllabus?
Everyone's got a copy.
Uh,
we may need some more in the
balcony. People need needs, bye.
They're hiding up there. Which uh,
David, do you have any extras or,
oh, okay. No, it's why
none left.
Okay.
We'll have more on Thursday
and I should put it on the web.
Dom,
I will put it up this afternoon.
We'll get it up on the web, uh,
through the registrar's site or however.
Um,
Teddy,
I'm going to take up the topic primarily
of why the American civil war period
has had,
still has such a hold
on the American and for that matter,
international historical imagination.
That's what I want to
talk about primarily,
but I want to say a word or two
about the structure of the course and
what you need to do as quickly
as possible. First of all,
every lecture, if you look
at the syllabus, has a topic,
a title of a kind.
I will not get behind spite
of what it may feel like.
The readings are listed
each week we are using,
among other things, there's a
combination of readings. In fact,
a rich combination of
historical monograph,
historical kind of syntheses two works
of fiction to novels worn by the Louisa.
May Alcott, a famous short, um,
classic little book
called Hospitals Sketches,
which was based on Alcotts
personal experience as a
nurse in civil war hospitals
and experienced that all bit overwhelmed
her emotionally, psychologically,
and she in some ways could not
stop thinking about it. Uh,
we also are reading using to readers
that is collections of documents.
One is a collection of documents by
mostly by and somewhat about Abraham
Lincoln,
a reader edited by Michael Johnson.
There's Nicole Ivy entering as we speak,
the eighth teaching assistant.
Sorry Nicole. We just did intros. Um,
anyway, one of the readers is,
is Lincoln the great speeches,
the great public letters.
We won't use every document in the book,
but the Great Lincoln stuff is all there
and well introduced the other reader,
which we use virtually
every week in the course.
And teaching assistants will be free
with this to assign whichever documents
they so choose. And any given week, I'm
still taking the plastic off the farm.
Um, it's edited by Bill Ganapathy,
Napa, great civil war historian,
recently deceased.
It's a collection of documents
from essentially the Mexican war,
right on through reconstruction.
Many of them very brief and
short documents allowing
us at times to teach with a
document.
It's possible you'll have an entire
discussion section that centers around a
single document as well as the other
reading you did his background.
Uh,
the other novel I neglected dimension is
a very new novel and I'm taking a risk
in this course for years and years.
I want to admit how many I've always
taught Michael Sharice great civil war
novel.
The killer angels,
which I would venture quarter of you
have probably already read. All right.
How many have already read killer angels?
We're not reading at this time.
You can't take that week off.
We're reading the Eel,
Dr Rosen new novel called the march,
which has only been out about
a year just into paperback.
It's doc doctor Oh,
the great modern novelists
of Urban America,
of,
of race in America have so many things.
He has actually a brilliant short
story in the current New Yorker.
If you haven't read it,
it may not appeal to all of you.
It's really about middle aged
men in the suburbs. I got it.
Um,
any rate dr o's March is about
Sherman's march to the sea.
It's about Sherman, but it's also
about all the people around him.
And I think Dr. Rowe accomplished
something extraordinary in that novel,
which so few American writers of fiction
I've ever quite been able to imagine.
He's not alone,
but not many have,
and that is fully realized
slave characters, those,
he invents a lot of real people
in that book and much of it,
like so many of other, uh, of Dr.
Rose. Great works like ragtime.
If you've read ragtime or others,
much of the much of the language,
the dialogue is verbatim
out of historical sources.
You might even want to reach Sherman's
memoirs in tandem with it if you have the
time, because the whole portions of it
come directly out of Sherman's memoirs.
Then there are characters invented around.
Anyway,
it's that last horrible,
devastating,
destructive,
evil,
sometimes good year and a half of the
civil war in Georgia and South Carolina
when the civil war became a
truly kind of total modern,
um, affair. Uh,
it's a novel about this
beast of war itself,
but it's very much a novel
about what this war was about.
Anyway.
Um,
I don't want to go into all the readings
were I divide this course in three
parts, which may or may not be obvious
the first time he glanced at the syllabus,
but essentially the first third of the
course is the coming of the civil war.
It's the story from roughly the
mid 1840s through fort Sumpter.
And the second,
third of the course is essentially the
war itself where we tackle not only how
the civil war was fought,
but we tackle what it was about.
We tackle the question of
confederate defeat and union victory.
How do we explain that? And we
especially tackle questions of meaning.
If a war is such a devastation
can have meaning in the end,
what are those meanings? It's, I think,
arguably the most important take home
set of questions and answers you might
take out of this course.
And of course that means we do
a good deal on emancipation,
the single most revolutionary
a result of the civil war.
And arguably the single most revolutionary
historical moment in American history,
the liberation of 4.2 million slaves to
some kind of freedom and some kind of
citizenship at least for a while.
And the third third of the
courses of course reconstruction,
that a brief shining moment is do boys,
one's called it of about 11 years from
the end of the civil for mathematics to
the disputed election of
1860 76 and 77 12 years,
one of the most vexing topsy turvy
turbulent embittered periods of American
history that historians still
fight over to say the least.
It is there what we'll try to
understand the consequences
of a civil war.
This is a course at the end of the day
about the causes and consequences as well
as the course of this event.
Now, um, but today is January 15th.
It is Martin Luther King's birthday.
I want to start with
a very famous passage.
It's not usually the
passage you hear from the,
I have a dream speech.
Almost always one of the dream speech
is quoted and now it's quoted in
commercials,
right?
Numerous times or in an radio spots,
background kings voices though it's some
kind of American chorus for what our,
when it went,
any moment we need to feel better about
ourselves and about race relations.
We often just skip right over the first
two or three paragraphs of the speech
where the central metaphor he sets up
in the speech is what he called the
promissory note
in the Bank of Justice.
I am happy to join with you today and
what will go down in history as the
greatest demonstration for freedom
in the history of our nation.
Okay.
And so we have come here,
excuse me,
five score years ago and here he is
drawing directly off Lincoln five score
years ago.
A great American in whose symbolic shadow
we stand today signed the emancipation
proclamation. This was of course, August,
1963 uh,
hot,
brutally hot August Day king on
the steps of the Lincoln Memorial.
This momentous decree came as a great
beacon light of hope to millions of Negro
slaves who had been seared in the
flames of withering injustice.
It came as a joyous daybreak.
He says 10 the long
night of their captivity,
that sentences almost
directly from the Bible,
but 100 years later,
the Negro still is not free.
100 years later,
the life of the Negro is
still sadly crippled by the
manacles of segregation and
the chains of discrimination.
100 years later,
the Negro lives on a lonely island of
poverty in the midst of a vast ocean of
material prosperity.
100 years later,
the Negro is still languished in the
corners of American society and finds
himself an exile in his own land.
Yeah,
and so we've come here today to dramatize
a shameful condition in a sense.
We've come here,
we've come to our nation's
capital to cash a check.
When the architects of our republic
wrote the magnificent words of the
constitution and the
declaration of independence,
they were signing a promissory note to
which every American was to fall heir.
This note was a promise that all men,
yes black men as well as white men would
be guaranteed the unalienable rights of
life, liberty, and the
pursuit of happiness.
It is obvious today that America has
defaulted on this promissory note insofar
as her citizens of color are concerned,
instead of honoring
this sacred obligation,
America has given the
Negro people a bad check,
a check which has come back
marked insufficient funds,
but we refused to believe that
the bank of justice is bankrupt.
We refuse to believe that there are
insufficient funds in the great vaults of
opportunity of this nation,
and so we've come to cash this check a
check that will give us upon demand the
riches of freedom and
the security of justice.
I would be thrilled if you walked
out of this course and we're
able to explain to somebody
why king made the promissory note,
the central metaphor of his.
I have a dream speech and
you could somehow explain
why it hadn't been cashed by
1963 and could then begin to discuss
whether it's fully cashed yet.
Now
that was just my homage to king.
Now,
um,
I like to do a little ritual at
the beginning of every class.
If you'll forgive me,
it only takes me about 10 seconds.
Do you know we live in a world where
all of us in this room take books for
granted? We throw books on the
floor, we throw books at people,
we load them in and out of our backpacks.
We drop him here and drop him there.
We lose them, we wrap them
up, we write all over them.
I wrote all over mine.
It's only a few generations ago when
there really weren't having any bookstores
to go to.
Your great,
great grandparents couldn't meander a
bookstore to speak up unless they lived in
a special section of a special city.
Books are precious things.
A lot of them are assigned in this
course. Short ones, little ones, big ones,
syntheses novels,
monographs.
Think of a book just for a moment
and then you can forget this.
If you want to think of a book,
any book,
it's hard to think of a really bad book
this way, but think of a good book,
one of your favorite books
ever as like a newborn child,
a newborn child brought
into the world a book.
Probably a lot more planning and thought
and design and construction at least
intellectually goes into that
book and it goes into, most babies
books have a cover. They have
beginnings, middles and ends.
There's somebodies dream,
there's somebody creation.
They never satisfy just like people,
but they're in some ways the greatest
things we have and sometimes it's nice to
remind ourselves of that in the places
where we take the most for granted.
I want a quote from for you to you,
I'm the oldest history book
in Western civilization,
not just because it's a book,
but I think this is a 0.1 can
make about any history course.
It doesn't what the subject is. It can
be social history, political history,
intellectual history, any history. It
can be the history of ancient Rome.
It could be post 1945 United States.
It could be any history,
but any history course
ought to do.
The two things that Herata named and the
opening sentence of the oldest history
book we have.
This is Heraclitus,
the history and a great, when you,
when you're writing the first book,
what are you going to call it?
The history,
no subtitles, nothing fancy. Just
I Herata test of can narcis m
here setting forth my history.
The time may not draw the color from
what man has broadened to being nor those
great and wonderful deeds manifested by
both the Greeks and the barbarians fail
of their report and
together we'll all of this,
the reason why they fought one another,
I don't know how closely
you listen to that,
but what does the rotted has just said.
He's basically said history is two things.
It's the story,
it's the color,
it's the great deeds.
It's the narrative that
takes you somewhere,
but it's also the reason why
it's also the explanation.
That's what history does.
It's supposed to do both of those things.
Some of us are more into the analysis
and we're not so fond of story.
Some of us just love stories and
don't care about the analysis.
I'll stop giving me all
that interpretation. Just
telling me the good story.
Again, this is what goes on of course
out in public history all the time.
Just tell us the old stories
or just sing us the old songs.
Make us feel good again.
Stop interpreting you historians
and worst of all, stop revising
you.
You how that word revision has crept into
our political culture on politicians.
Don't like the arguments of
people would disagree with them.
They accused him of being
revisionist historian.
It was even a poll tested word for awhile
when Condoleezza Rice was using it.
Revision is revisionist
as though all history isn't revisionist.
Now,
favorite story about revisionism is my
buddy Eric Foner was on a talk show once
by 1992 he was not one of those
shouting talk shows with Lynne Cheney.
Who would that?
Dick Cheney's wife who was then head of
the Neh and this was a time you won't
remember this.
We were having this national Brouhaha
over what were called national history
standards and Lynne Cheney of m,
a real critic of these national history
standards cause he didn't particularly
like some of the ideas that the
historians were coming up with.
It's on his talk show.
It was firing line or you get two people
on this shout at each other for an hour
or half hour and the producers love it
and phoner is pretty good at rapid fire
coming back. He's pretty
good at that. Anyway,
they had this sit too and she had kept
accusing him and other historians of
being revisionist.
And Eric says,
the next morning he got a phone call
from a reporter at Newsweek and she said,
professor phoner, um, when did
all this revisionism begin?
If owner said, probably with
Heraclitus and the Newsweek had,
porter said,
do you have his phone number?
Never underestimate the
ignorance. Hl. Mencken said this,
I did never underestimate the
ignorance of the American people
or if journalist or of
no,
as to this question of why the civil
war has a hold on us or a hold on a
historical imagination in this country.
There are many,
many ways to think about that.
I'm going to take you through seven or
eight possible answers to that in just a
moment. Almost like a list, but again,
sometimes if you go back
to the oldest explanations,
you find things that we haven't
thought about in facilities.
The Peloponnesian war, the first great
modern text in Western civilization.
At any rate about a civil war,
the great Greek civil war,
and through acidities great work,
he has this little sentence or he actually
captures a good deal about why civil
wars are such vexing,
difficult problems in nations memories
once they've had them. There's this,
the acidities said quote,
the people made their recollections
fit in with their sufferings.
They began to tell a story that
reflected their own suffering.
Now they hear might be white southerners.
They suffered,
they lost it,
were truly defeated.
Conquered.
That's suffering might
be African Americans.
Emancipation wasn't a day of jubilee.
It was an agonizing, horrible,
terrible,
sometimes wonderful set of
experiences into the unknown
and the suffering might
be northern unionist. Yes,
about 300,000 Yankees soldiers
died in the civil war and about
650 to 700,000 were wounded
people,
made their memories fit their sufferings.
I also like this little passage,
they're just put into your craw
about any history course I bought any
interpretation,
and of course I'm going to have a
point of view at times in this course.
All historians do don't have been listened
to a historian if he or she doesn't
have a point of view.
None of us are blank slates.
None of us can just
tell it like it was the op interpreting,
please.
Okay?
But I always try to
remember William James,
this passage and one of his
pragmatism essays, and I say,
I think that should be required
for us citizenship. If you know,
if I ruled the world and you'd have
to read this for us. Citizenship
in it.
James says,
the greatest enemy of any one of
my truths is the rest of my truth.
It's as though James is
saying, damn, every time I
think I really know something.
That's the truth. Along comes
some other possible truth in it.
Screws it up.
Yeah.
Why can't history just be
settled and not far ready?
If it was, it wouldn't be any fun. It was,
it wouldn't be interesting but was,
it wouldn't be good for business either
now.
Okay.
Why does the civil war have a whole,
why are you here at 280 of you
here for a course on the civil war?
I know it fits 10 30 on Tuesday,
Thursday a hundred other reasons you
want to lecture course lots of possible
answers to all that kind of question,
but why does this event
hold people there now?
Approximately 65,000 books that have
been written on the American civil war.
This doesn't even really include
the books on reconstruction
that had been written since Apple
Maddix. Now I realized recently in, uh,
giving a public talk that you can't
always say since happen Maddix and people
know what you mean.
I'm going to assume Yale students do,
but that's actually where the surrender
was signed to end of the civil.
I was giving a talk recently and I said
before Appomattox and after Fmx and Emma
said that four or five times,
one of the first questions in Q and a
is this woman innocently asked what,
what has happened?
Maddix oh dear.
Well you see ma'am. Anyway,
since [inaudible] 65,
you know what that is?
That's more than one per day had been
published in this country on this event.
Why?
What does Robert Penn Warren mean when
he said the civil war draws us as an
oracle darkly on riddled in poor tentious
of our personal and our national fate?
That's pretty grandiose language.
But what did Warren mean?
What a Gertrude Stein mean when she
said there never will be anything more
interesting then that American
civil war of all people,
Gertrude Stein was hopelessly
interested in this event.
Oh, never will be anything more
interesting than that. American civil war.
She said,
why are so many people into this?
Why do people want to read about it?
Reenact it, go play it. Go visit it.
Is it just heritage tourism?
Is it Josh?
The attraction of military history?
What is it that compels us to
remember the most divisive,
the most bloody, the most tragic
event in our national history?
Okay,
and how do we remember it?
Have we sometimes cleaned it up with
such pleasing mythology that we've just
made it fun?
Why is the confederate flag a problem?
Why doesn't it just go away?
It's the second most ubiquitous
American symbol across the world,
especially since Michael
Jordan quit playing,
other than the u s flag,
the confederate flags and most ubiquitous
symbol of the United, maybe Coca Cola.
Okay?
But Coca Cola is an international symbol.
Now you can find the confederate
flag everywhere in this world.
I spent a year in Germany and I
traveled a lot in eastern Europe.
I saw it all over the place.
I was in Prague,
the Czech Republic in 1993 Jim Mcpherson
is battle cry of freedom book your
assigned largely as background,
largest selling book on the American
civil war, published in the last 25 years.
International best seller was 16 weeks
in New York Times bestseller list was
translated into Czech.
I mean,
nobody reads check except the checks
and even them even they tend to read
fiction in German.
Anyone in the bookstore,
they had a big display and Jim
Mcpherson's battle cry of freedom.
The whole bookstore window,
I couldn't believe it,
but how did they display
it with confederate flags?
They missed the point of the
title of the book, but nevermind.
How do you portray the American
symbol wars symbolically? Oh,
it's that confederate flag that will tell
us right away with this is about why.
Why does this confederate
flag just go away
or put it another way?
Why do you love the civil war?
I can't tell you how many thousands of
times in public lectures, et Cetera,
et Cetera, et cetera. In my
end, all civil war historians,
faceless people will come up afterwards.
Usually they want to show you the
grandfather's letters, but they'll say,
I just love the civil war
and you want to just stop
them for a moment and say
you need a shrink or what is it you love?
Is it the aftermath it in Tetum?
Is it the trenches of Spotsylvania?
Is it the latrines at Andersonville?
Is it both killing Lincoln?
What is it you love it?
Is it because we love epics?
This is it because a lot of people
really are kind of hard wired.
Maybe we may even be hard
wired biologically for
story. I can't prove that,
but there's a lot of research on this.
Are we hard wired for story and therefore
to some degree for epic stories that
have heroes and villains and beginnings
and ends and great collisions,
maybe.
Is it because Americans love redemption
and people around the world love to
think that about us sometimes too.
Is it because we liked to see or
we've converted this terribly divisive
experience into a great unifier?
Did we go back and look at the civil war,
not only to see the beginnings of our
own modern time and a modern American
nation,
a second American republic born out of
the death of the first and so on and so
forth,
but do we actually go back to this most
dividing experience to figure out how
are we became unified?
Or as William Dean Howells put it
in 1900 and a lovely line, he said,
what the American people always like is
a tragedy as long as they can give it a
happy ending.
Is it because we see the American
civil war or have learned to see it as
America's first great racial reckoning?
We're the nation's national sin of slavery
as some like to put it had to finally
be remitted in some way, purged, cleansed,
and the language used by both sides in
this war of purgings and cleansings,
the war that brought a reckoning
from 250 years of slavery,
destroyed a slave society brought the end
of the first American republic and the
revolution of emancipation.
I think there's a lot to argue
that Americans have big gun,
at least they've just begun this to
love the civil war because they love
emancipation.
They want to live in the
nation that freed slaves.
My favorite line in George Bush,
the first inaugural address in 1989
and I'm probably the only one that ever
bothered to remember this line.
Maybe the only one who cares,
but Peggy Noonan wrote him a sentence.
It's classic inaugural rhetoric.
It comes right and it comes right after
the section and Bush ones inaugural
where he's two. He's saying, we must
put the war in Vietnam. Behind us.
It is too definitive and so on.
And there's a line where he says,
we must remember, we are the nation
that sent 600,000 of its sons to die.
Rather than have slavery
now,
who wouldn't want to live in that country?
That's a great line in an
inaugural address. Of course,
it's ignoring the fact that at least
half of those people died to preserve
slavery,
but nevermind.
Do we love the civil war because sometimes
there's a lot of guilty pleasure or
not so guilty pleasure
and just loving the details of military
history and if you're one of those,
fine. That's great. I had that stage two,
I will confess if you make me,
but what is all that nostalgia
about for those battlefield?
Yeah,
or is it because this experience in
American history is ultimately about loss?
Are we attracted to loss?
Is loss more interesting sometimes than
victory and by loss, I mean defeat,
but also loss in terms of human life,
treasure proportions of
civilizations that die.
Take loss for just a moment.
If you took the 620,000 out of
Americans who died in the civil war,
you moved it ahead to the Vietnam era
and roughly the 12 years in the United
States fought in Vietnam per capita.
Okay.
Approximately 4 million Americans
would have died in Vietnam.
That's the scale of death and
loss and the civil war. 4 million
Americans will never sustain for a million
casualties in a war. I would argue,
I mean, I can't prove that. I mean,
unless Osama bin Ladin is coming
through that window, who knows?
Maybe he will one day.
Would that be cool?
I mean that you wouldn't
slip through that lecture,
but I don't think Americans will
ever sustain that Chi. But 4 million,
if you came per capita from the civil
war era population to the era of Vietnam
every year at Antietam in rural Maryland
on the anniversary of the battle,
17th of September.
Yeah.
They put out a little Illuminati
or the Luminari. Excuse me. Uh,
no, no. Whoa.
That's a slip I luminaria or the little,
the little candle lamps
all over the battlefield.
They put 23,000 of them out,
which was the number of casualties in
eight hours at Antietam and when the sun
goes down,
you can look at the battlefield and
get a sense of this kind of powerful,
almost artistic sense of the loss.
Every one of those little
candle lights wasn't human life.
Um,
related to that is the
American imagination for this
event still stimulated in
part because sometimes
we just like lost causes.
We are attracted to defeat
sometimes more than we are attracted
to victory.
Wasson war is sometimes more interesting.
Lost Causes Somehow
represent the rebel spirit,
a rebellious spirit,
an insurrectionary spirit.
And in surgeon spirit,
some people may be attracted in that way
and maybe last but not least in
this list could go on and on.
There is,
I think an interest in the civil war among
serious readers in particular because
it does have somehow house
satisfy that search we offer.
It's an [inaudible] for origins.
The origins of the modern nation state,
the origins of big government,
the origins of centralized power,
the origins of what seemed to
be the death of state's rights,
but should surely didn't die,
did it?
We have a states rights supreme
court now in case you didn't notice
the birth of a kind of modernity in
America and many form comes out of this
year. It doesn't just come out
of the battle of Gettysburg,
but it surely comes out of the euro.
There's also this sense in which somehow
in that experience of the civil war in
the middle of the 19th century fought
for the existence of an American nation
and for the new definition of that nation
and just how free and equal the people
in it would be
is where we may somehow see
that transformation from a
premodern to a more modern world.
And sometimes I suspect
that's what attracts.
Now the watch is, I only have about
two minutes, so let me leave you here.
I do think sometimes
we're attracted because war
is just so big. Geiling Lee,
fascinating and drew Faust.
I'm wonderful historian whom you now know
as the president of Harvard University
has just published a brand new book.
It's literally just out this week.
I read it in manuscript,
but I have a blurb on the back.
It's called the Republic of suffering
and she has much to say in that book,
which I highly recommend
about why death is so interesting.
Let me leave you with this Thursday.
I'm going to take up the old south and
begin this comparison of the old south to
the growing capitalist that both
sides were highly capitalists,
northern society,
but in 1850 or 1840s America
you could find both extremes of,
on the one hand,
a tremendous,
seemingly unfathomable
optimism about America.
It seemed to be limitless and boundless
and nobody captured it ever any better
than Walt Whitman,
but you can also find
expressions all over the culture,
especially from African Americans and
abolitionist and some slave holders of a
great dread about the
direction of the country.
In Whitman's first line of his drum taps,
his color,
his famous collection of civil war poetry
comes that phrase which is up here
first though songs for a prelude
and that first poem and drum taps is
a Whitman trying to capture just how
exciting war can be. But he'd also
written a poem like democracy,
and I'll leave you with this and I'll
start with a response to it on Thursday in
Whitman's democracy as well as
several other Whitman poems,
you can find this limitless
sense of optimism.
Just listened to his words,
sail,
sail.
That best ship of democracy
of value is by freight.
Tis not the president only the past
is also stored in the this America,
this thing called America to him
is the whole world's new beginning.
Thou holdest not the venture of myself
alone, not the western continent alone.
Earth's resume,
entire floats on Die Keel.
Oh ship is steadied by an ice spar
with the time voyages in trust,
the antecedent nations sink or swim with
the America is everything according to
Whitman, with all their ancient
struggles, martyrs, heroes, epics,
wars,
thou barest the other continents.
There's, there's as much as the line,
the destination port triumphant,
steer them with good, strong
hand and wary eye. Oh,
helmsmen thou carious great companion.
How can I pierce the impenetrable
blank of your future?
I feel I ominous greatness,
evil as well as good.
I watched the advancing, absorbing,
the present, transcending the past.
I see that light lighting and eye
shadow shadowing as if the entire globe,
but I do not undertake to define
the hardly can I comprehend the
well, that's Whitman saying
as we all do at times,
America is an idea.
This course is the story of what
that idea was and what happened to it
and the chance it had coming out of it.